in this capsule we will see how we
can solve a problem of
satisfaction constraint with the
research the cable so we saw in
local search that these are types
algorithms that are appropriate
when we want to solve our problems and
that the path between the initial state
then the final solution and not really
important that all that interests us
in fact to find it's and ultimately who
is that satisfied that corresponds to a
solution to our problem is actually a
satisfaction problem against it is
like that is to say that all that
we are interested is the final assignment
of all the variables that corresponds to
an assignment therefore complete and
competitive
so it turns out that as we go the
see that we can solve a problem of
constraint satisfaction with a
local search algorithm like
bing or simulate denis line a site 8
any search box
local we saw the previous capsules
and in this case also what we actually
is that we are told in our
search would match an assignment
which is complete but not necessarily
compatible
and then what we could do is
make local transitions on
would change the assignments in our
assignment complete so as to
minimize the number of conflicts like
besides we saw that not tell me is
real name could use from the
local search for to solve it
so any point of
satisfaction constraints way
similar to solve them with the
local search
the problem is that research
local can fall into optimal
local so what does that mean
is that we are not guaranteed
find the solution that provides
no conflict therefore to satisfy all
our countries but it turns out that between
others for the problem of would like the
search keeps it calm works the
market particularly well and find
the exact solution to our problem is
among others, the sentry box that we will see
which is the algorithm in conflict
works surprisingly well so
because if our objectives function
we will try to
bet that's going to be the number of conflicts
so the number of constraints that are
not satisfied by our assignment and
the transitions that we will do is
changes to the assignment of a
variable we will change the destination
from one variable to another in order to
to minimize more and more the number of
conflicts until and hopefully
arrive at an assignment with zero
so entrusts the algorithm in complicated goes
as we will see gathered from the nile
like bing but with an appearance
stochastic
here is the office kde I had to be a
simple game without means on the water the
little local to see him well understand
what is the sentry box so we
starts with a state that is a
assignment that is going to be an assignment
random and complete so random that
means that she will probably not
therefore compatible purely
random take each of the variables
of our problem to assign them to you
at one of their possible value little
matter if it generates conflicts or
not alas for a number
iterations or number of iterations vote
is specified a parameter of my
in conflict function of my algorithms
at each iteration what I do I
turn my assignment is compatible
if this is the case because we are working
always with full assignments
we found a solution they can
return the assignment
and if it's not like we're going to continue
will choose a variable x which we will
change the assignment is actually that
will do what this variable is going there
choose randomly from all
possible variables for my problem of
constraint satisfaction then of that
we will choose a value from
domain values ​​of my chosen variable
is the value we will choose is
the one that satisfies the most
constraints in which is involved
x so we change the value we want
change the value of my variable x for
a small empty value that is such
we will have the least amount of conflict
possible and what we do is we
change assignment 1
a change the value that was signed
x for this to be the value but we
found one that satisfies the most
constraints
so there was the slightest conflict and
unitary like this many times
until we hope to find a
assignment that she votes is compatible
we will be able to return
otherwise we'll stop have come out of the
mouth then we will return once we
feel we are failing we have not managed to
satisfy all so understands what
is the gorilla that is very very
simple and surprisingly a
problem with a million reindeers this is
possible to solve it
about 50 steps and so that can
look surprising
the reason for the success of the research the
case the algorithm inc in cop sedan
problem as big as that is when
you are the problem of a million reign
of a general drainer he does not exist
only one solution but there is
exist several
and these solutions are only offered
intuitively scattered everywhere
in the space that makes it
possible difficult whether it is to fall
almost by chance on his solutions there
and so by what really exists
a lot of solutions that's going to be
possible same problem with miller to a
million reign to find the solution
is actually this algorithm years they have
been used previously to make the
observation schedules for the robot
space telescope and the great they
used before could take three
weeks to make a six o'clock water
while with the mincom cops are
have come to solve this problem of
satisfaction of constraints to find
a schedule this holiday unconstrained
of use in just 10 minutes